lethal action speaks louder than words
this is the message russia sent as their
delegates were talking with ukraine
negotiators
civilians attacked in their homes
ukrainian authorities report deaths and
scores of injuries in hakeev
the attacks targeted civilian areas in
and around ukraine's second city
they appear to include cluster munitions
by nightfall on monday the capital kiev
came under heavy russian bombardment
just as the talks were winding up for
the day
ukrainian and russian delegations today
held the first round of talks the main
aim of which was to discuss the
ceasefire and cessation of hostilities
in the territory of ukraine
the negotiations lasted approximately
five hours during which time we went in
detail through every point on the agenda
we found a few points that we can use as
a prognosis of our joint positions and
the most important is that we agreed to
continue the process of the
negotiations the negotiations held on
the belarus ukraine border lasted five
hours there were no breakthroughs
however the two sides agreed to continue
talking in a second session if anything
the fighting has worsened
before the talk started vladimir
zelinski called on the eu to allow his
country to join the block and signed an
accession document
he had made another defiant statement
the fifth day of the full-scale war of
russia against the people of ukraine we
stand strong we've lived through that
much over the past days what other
people wouldn't experience in decades
in the south of ukraine where russian
forces have advanced and taken the city
of berdyansk these are civilians
surrounding russian military vehicles
they shouted go home to the
troops such defiance and solidarity is
seen all over ukraine
in every town in every city there's a
determination a resolve to help the war
effort in any way people can
a steady stream of donated supplies for
the army is being handed over to this
voluntary organization in la vie
it's helpers who are students don't
believe russia is interested in peace
they're still fighting us they're still
launching their rockets on our territory
and the talks are going on so how's it
impossible have talks while fighting us
upstairs donated medical supplies and
drugs all date checked are processed and
local stores ensure they meet a constant
demand for soldiers boots i and my
colleagues are doing all the best here
in a safe place to
collect the help from ukraine and from
ukrainians and foreigners all around the
world
but no matter how strong the resolve of
ukrainian forces might be
these satellite images are now showing
an armored column to the northwest of
kiev
that's nearly 30 kilometers long
and it's edging closer to the capital
now
only 20 kilometers from the city center
andrew simmons al jazeera level